[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
handball ce week-end trappe s'est
facilement imposé kung fu argenté en 32e
de finale de la coupe de france sur le
score de 34 à 25
retour sur l'exploit du petit poucet
yvelinois dans quelques instants ce
rugby et montigny le bretonneux a repris
le chemin de la compétition ce dimanche
contre marcoussis à domicile malgré une
belle résistance des minimes 1 se sont
inclinés 18 à 11 et reste à la sixième
place du championnat de promotion
honneur résumer à suivre foot us les
templiers d'elancourt reprennent le
championnat de deuxième division ce
week-end pour leur premier match de la
saison les élans courtois accueilleront
les vikings de villeneuve d'ascq pour
nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevrons dans ce magazine des membres
de l'équipe
coup de projecteur à frein à présent sur
les principaux résultats du week-end
dans le département
on commence donc par du handball ont
joué ce week-end les 32e de finale de la
coupe de france trappe qui évolue en
excellence départementale recevait
argenteuil une équipe de prérégion
malgré cette division ad car les
trappistes ont réalisé l'exploit de se
qualifier sans forcer pour le tour
suivant
score final 34 à 25 le résumé le montage
est signée romain au russe finit une
qualification historique trappe une
équipe profonde en 2014 va accéder aux
seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france après sa victoire 34 à 25 contre
argenteuil résultats acquis en première
période les trappistes comptait six buts
d'avancé à la mi temps
franchement aujourd'hui ça a été fait
dès la première mi temps parce que pour
nous on s'est préparé à ce match là on a
tout donné dans les dix premières
minutes et on a fait la différence dès
le début on a senti que c'était pas si
l'après pour nous on a tendance à dire
que les dix premières minutes de chaque
mi temps
c'est là où se fait la différence et les
joueurs ont répondu présent donc là
c'était en tant que coach là c'était
parfait pour continuer son épopée trèbes
s'est appuyé pendant la partie sur une
grosse activité offensive avec des
gestes spectaculaires en première
période
autre point fort de l'équipe sur ce
match la défense les trappistes selon
concédé que 25 buts face à argenteuil
une formation qui évolue pourtant une
division au dessus des trappistes
début d'année on prenait une trentaine
de buts 32 buts par match et on a fait
un gros travail de défense pour préparer
ce match
donc l'objectif a été rempli qu'on est
en défense faut être agressif faut
montrer qu'on est présent sur le terrain
donc on l'a montré en défense on a
essayé de monter de la barre rapidement
pour
voilà pour apprendre davantage une
combativité qu'il faudra conserver au
tour suivant trap est désormais le petit
poucet d'île de france qui pourrait
affronter pendant les finales régionales
bondoufle mennessis brille sur vingt
trois équipes de prérégion la rencontre
soit programmé le week-end du 18 février
mais en attendant le club peut savoir
[Musique]
toujours handball c'est un petit
événement chez les féminines monti le
bretonneux a remporté ce week-end son
tout premier match de la saison dans le
championnat de nationale 2 lésiné
montaigne se sont imposés 31 à 18 contre
aubervilliers lors de la 9e journée au
classement avec cette victoire l'équipe
de montils bretonneux reste dernière du
championnat la 12e place mais compte
seulement deux points de retard sur le
premier non relégable
nous allons maintenant à quitter lé
ballon de handball pour les as ballon
ovale en promotion honneur de rugby
monty l'aube retenues s'est incliné 18 à
11 ce week-end contre marcoussis à
domicile leur sixième défaite de la
saison en dix matches disputés retour
sur la rencontre avec nicolas d'andré
c'est la pénalité du bonus défensif
montigny le bretonneux se contentera de
ce point une défaite 11 à 18 face à
marcoussis lors de la première mi temps
les deux équipes ont commis de nombreux
en avants après 20 minutes de jeu le
score est toujours vierge mais montigny
le bretonneux débloque la situation
après une mêlée le demi d'ouverture tape
un coup de pied par dessus pour lui même
plaquée au sol il réussit à transmettre
l'ailier remet intérieur au numéro 13
pour inscrire le premier essai de la
rencontre après une pénalité convertie
en fin de première période montigny mène
8 0 à la pause on a su rester dans le
match sur la première mi temps on a su
proposer du jeu collectivement ce qu'on
n'a pas réussi à faire sur les matches
précédents et c'est ça qu'on relève
qu'on va relever aujourd'hui et qu'on a
eu la force mentale d'aller chercher le
bonus défensif dans les dernières
minutes
la seconde période a basculé en faveur
de marcoussis revenus des vestiaires
avec un jeu plus direct sans séquences
de passes et des avants dominateurs les
essonniens réussissent à inscrire une
pénalité et trois essais dont celui ci
après une touche et un maul qui
s'écroule dans l'en but signé mon teint
ensuite on a commencé à subir dans les
impacts
marcoussis a pris le dessus face aux
logiques
ce qui est intéressant c'est que des
faits pas des génies il faut pas oublier
que c'est les leaders de la poule et
qu'ils ont des joueurs à des postes clés
qui font la différence c'est qu'ils ont
réussi à remettre la balle
la main sur la balle au classement
marcoussis conserve sa seconde place
montigny le bretonneux pointe au 6e rang
prochain match dimanche 21 janvier face
au troisième de la poule garches
vaucresson
à notre résultat de rugby mais cette
fois ci en fédérale 2 le promu plaisir
ohana rien pu faire sur le terrain de
bobigny ce dimanche plaisir s'est
largement incliné 71 à trois à
l'extérieur à l'occasion de la 12e
journée
au classement les yvelinois reste 10e du
championnat xxi points d'avancé sur le
premier relégable
arras et neuf sur la lanterne rouge
domont le maintien semble se dessiner à
pur plaisir
en football petit exploit de versailles
en coupe gambardella la coupe de france
des moins de 19 ans les versets qui
évolue en r2 se sont imposés 2-1 ce
dimanche votre show les clubs de r1 et
deux buts ont été inscrits par sami à
matougues eu le tirage au sort des 32e
de finale aura lieu ce jeudi
le prochain match sera quant à lui
programmé le dimanche 4 février après le
soccer nous avons parlé de football
américain les templiers d'elancourt
reprennent le championnat de deuxième
division ce week-end pour ce premier
match de la saison les élans courtois
reçoivent les vikings de villeneuve
d'ascq ce samedi soir pour nous parler
de cette reprise nous recevons sur ce
plateau le directeur sportif frédéric
anderson le joueur dominique
mozziconacci l'ancien président et
aujourd'hui membre du bureau georges
agostino et le nouveau président joël da
silva bonsoir sont souvent alors avant
de parler du match nous allons revenir
sur la grande nouvelle qui a bouleversé
on peut dire l'intersaison des templiers
d'elancourt la passation de pouvoir au
niveau de la présidence georges agostino
pourquoi avez vous décidé de quitter le
club va fuser 17 ans vous étiez au club
à la tête du club en 17 ans au président
oui effectivement est depuis l'origine
du club dans trois ans comme tu vas te
le dire c'est une passation c'est un
passage de relais et il était temps que
il ya un peu de sang neuf au sein des
templiers
après pour des raisons personnelles je
pars bientôt à la retraite dans deux
trois ans donc voilà le petit de
passation comme ça
le club des torpilles est un club sain
il n'y a pas eu de
discussion autres c'était vraiment un
passage de témoin il ya une usure
peut-être au fur et à mesure des années
on va dire ça mais du sang neuf bons une
mesure à force de faire ouais il est
tout dire on va dire ça oui
joël da silva vous êtes désormais le
nouveau président est ce que vous allez
dans la continuité de georges agostino
voilà enfin une mesure du temps je pense
pour le moment oui on va être dans la
continuité de ce qui a été fait aux le
club ça fait plus de trente ans qu'il
existe donc ya pas de raison de passer à
une révolution immédiatement d'accord ce
n'est pas trop dur de succéder à un
monument comme georges agostino bien sûr
qui connaît tout le monde donc la ville
connaît tout le monde dans la vie
quasiment donc ça a été un peu plus
compliquée oui ça peut vous perturber
vous les joueurs ce changement au niveau
de la présidence
quelques jours la reprise niveau bureaux
non je pense pas on n'est pas un super
contacter pas par ce qui se passe sur le
bureau nous c'est plus le terrain avec
hammerson vous allez directeur sportif
vous êtes dit maladie oui et puis de
toute façon la direction du club était
assez on a un bureau à s'étoffer
on a une structure qui en place qu'on a
étoffé ses dernières années et du coup
le projet à saint changer donc c'est
plus un changement de visage et objectif
reste restent les mêmes toujours de
gagner de performer au plus haut niveau
possible et vous allez continuer à
suivre le club bien sûr bien sûr je vais
toujours là présent samedi soir déjà
du coup on va on va parler du match de
samedi soir ferait ce début de saison de
deuxième division vous le sentez comment
fallait car personne va bien c'est avec
impatience surtout parce que ça fait
longtemps qu'on prépare notre saison
c'est un peu achevée prématurément
l'année dernière début mai et depuis et
depuis on pense à cette saison et puis
depuis la rentrée en septembre
on travaille on poursuit les efforts qui
ont été accomplis l'année dernière et on
espère que cette année on va pouvoir
franchir un palier et pouvoir enfin
atteindre nos objectifs
comment vous sentez le groupe cette
année beaucoup
ainsi au niveau des présences au niveau
du travail personnel en dehors du club
en plus de plus de sérieux plus
d'assiduité aux entraînements et
d'assiduité et plus de sérieux l'envié
de faire plus que les dernières
l'objectif président ça sera de remonter
cette saison dans un premier temps c'est
assez mérité la première division il ya
dedans mais dans un premier temps on
savait bien avant les play-offs et puis
après on verra fait religieux chaque
match viendra jean-jacques aussi beau
penser que c'est possible à la montée
cette année c'est possible parce que
c'est souhaitable je sais pas c'est une
équipe relativement jeune depuis la
dernière bon là ils vont prendre une
saison de plus il faut encore sûrement
étoffer un peu le vivier est que ces
jeunes et l'expérience mais c'est
abordable on va voir les deux trois
premiers matches qui vont me donner le
tempo de la saison l'équipe va-t-elle se
renforçait que d import us généralement
il y en a deux chaque année aux
templiers certainement certain nombre en
prenant au moins 1 de 10,6 quelques
matchs qui devrait arriver bientôt et de
toute façon le l'américain c'est
toujours un plus mais la base de
l'équipe ça restait joueurs qui sont
déjà présents qui travaille depuis
plusieurs années sur le projet qu'on
essaie de développer les américains ils
viennent ils s'en vont c'est toujours un
atout en plus sur l'effectif parce
qu'ils ont ils ont plus de métier un
niveau supérieur mais messi autour de
surve autour de l'américain la structure
et de la structure le reste de l'équipe
est faible ça fera pas de différence ça
permettra pas forcément d'atteindre les
objectifs juste parce qu'on a un
américain cette année encore vous avez
choisi expand com jeanne internet match
com quarterbacks de l'équipe
pourquoi faire confiance à un joueur
français puis survient joueurs
américains on a déjà eu largement le
niveau pour mener l'équipe il connaît le
système parfaitement il peut communiquer
facilement avec les joueurs vu qu'il est
français et ça fait partie aussi la
volonté qu'on avait mise en place au
début du projet de de former un
quaterback france est davantage de
prendre un quarterbacks penser c'est
qu'on peut prendre n'importe sur une
autre position aussi donc ça c'est
avantage non négligeable
dominique vous êtes d'accord avec
fallait qu anderson d'accord c'est le
quota est parfait pour les templiers
d'elancourt
c'est le bon coordonne ce qu'il faut et
avec ben en fait oui je suivais l'osmose
avec lui sur le terrain parce que
parfait je ne sais pas si on peut dire
parfait mais je pense que c'est le
quarterback qu'il nous faut ce premier
match contre les big thing va-t-il être
décisif président le début de saison
mais celui-là qui donne un peu le tempo
des favoris
on est favori logique au sénat ouais je
pense aussi oui on les a battus à leur
tour l'année dernière avec une équipe
qui était encore moins d'expérience que
cette année donc il y avait c'était une
nouvelle équipe est dernière donc je
pense qu'on est favoris oui d'accord
victoire vous êtes tous unanimes autour
de cette table vous êtes favoris là on
entre et merci à tous les cas dépasser
sur ce plateau vous souhaite beaucoup de
réussite pour cette saison le premier
match des templiers donc programmé ce
samedi à 20 heures au complexe sportif
europe à elancourt résumer à suivre
lundi prochain sur tv à 78 du cyclisme
à présent le parcours officiel du paris
nice 2018 a été dévoilée ce mardi à
versailles par les organisateurs comme
chaque année depuis neuf ans le peloton
s'élancera le dimanche 4 mars depuis les
yvelines château et la petite commune
d'orson huiles sont les villes étapes de
ce tracé les détails à remontage de
romain respini après voilà c'est en 2017
c'est au tour de chatou d'être ville
départ du paris nice le 4 mars prochain
le peloton s'élancera pour un départ
fictif de l'île des impressionnistes
avant un départ réel à four que et
cyclistes passeront ensuite par
villepreux et villiers saint frédéric
avant de s'engouffrer dans la vallée de
chevreuse on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous on va aller chercher
la coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi ses
démons ses deux sont des endroits qui
parle et un retour sur saint quentin en
yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud le
tracé de cette première étape de 135 km
a été imaginé pour apporter du suspense
à la course comme paris nice se joue à
quelques secondes près les secondes qui
seront prises ou perdu dès le premier
dimanche dans les humains contre ans
sans aucun doute eu jours après sur la
promenade des anglais
le lendemain le peloton prendra le
départ de la deuxième étape depuis le
village d'orson vie d'une commune de
moins de 400 habitants située dans les
environs de saint-arnaud livre
moi je trouve ça bien parce que le vélo
c'est pas que le tour de france des
épreuves comme paris nice ça permet
aussi à des communes qui n'ont peut-être
pas toujours les moyens d'accueillir le
tour de france afin d'avoir une épreuve
cycliste de renom avec des coureurs de
renom et et puis ben faire plaisir à
tout le monde aux habitants aux gamins
des écoles pas loin en quoi c'est bien
une nouvelle accueillie avec
enthousiasme par les habitants de la
commune qui pourront croiser les stars
du cyclisme français comme arnaud démare
aux varennes barguil oui je suis
contente je suis pas trop cycliste moi
mais mon conjoint je suis donc on va
sûrement aller voir les les coureurs ça
va peut-être dynamiser un peu le village
quoi là parce que c'est un petit peu
calme quoique faire découvrir un peu aux
gens du village dans son ville il fois
le départ donné les 22 équipes cyclistes
rouleront pendant quatre kilomètres
avant de quitter le département des
yvelines pour l'eure et loir ils
reviendront en 2019 pour une nouvelle
édition
on continue à parler de cyclisme il n'y
aura pas de nouveau record pour le super
centenaires robert marchand le sportif
de 106 ans qui avait réalisé en 2010 7
22 points 5 km en 1h au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
est officiellement à la retraite le
sportif d'un mètre cinquante annoncé je
cite qu'il avait la tension qui
déconnait pourtant l'année dernière il
avait l'air d'en avoir encore sous la
nous avions eu sa réaction juste
après son record j'ai problème l'atelier
lady gaga minutes sinon j'arrête
d'époque et bolbec
justement les salles j'attendais j'ai
connu encore un superbe record pour
robert marchand un grand bravo en tout
cas hameau de banten à présent les
volants d'elancourt ont organisé ce
week-end leur 17e tournoi de doubles au
palais des sports l'événement a réuni
plus de 350 participants venus de 89
clubs français le samedi des matchs
hommes et femmes étaient programmés et
le dimanche c'est au tour des doubles
mixtes une tradition selon le président
du club des vollandes élan pour et
organisateur de l'événement éric boyer
le badminton c'est un des premiers
sports qui a été réellement mixte
olympique
donc c'est le mix est très important de
vagues hinton donc un tournoi double
sens double mixte ça peut pas faire le
premier double mixte a été programmée
aux jeux olympiques d'atlanta en 1996
heil en cours ce dimanche dans la
catégorie double mixte c'est la paire
magali burkel et bas comme richard qui a
remporté la compétition
les autres résultats sont à retrouver
sur le site internet du club qui
s'affiche à l'écran en passe maintenant
à la rubrique agenda
on commence cet agenda part du karaté
plaisir va accueillir les championnats
des yvelines cadets minimes et juniors
kata et combat ce samedi dimanche au
palais des sports de la ville nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir sur ce plateau
yves etienne président du karaté club
plaisir wa quels il ya joue entraîneur
dans la structure et moussali sportif au
sein du club
bonsoir parce qu'en faisant président
c'est une première pour le club pourquoi
avez vous décidé d'organiser cette
compétition était votre choix
ou plutôt le choix de la ligue de karaté
des îles basses et une entente mutuelle
c'est à dire que le karaté club de
plaisir doit se faire connaître un petit
peu plus dans la région on a déjà
beaucoup de résultats mais on voulait
aussi organisé à avoir des événements
parce qu'on a des infrastructures qui
sont extrêmement de bonne qualité et
donc le comité départemental a demandé à
ce que l'on soit le accueille ce
championnat et du cou avait répondu
favorablement tout de suite totalement
alors vous avez à l'heure actuelle 211
licenciés au sein du club
l'organisation d'un tel événement
peut-elle attirer plus de monde aussi
ceux de la structure bien sûr c'est pour
faire plus qu'un objectif
coup de projecteur coup de projecteur et
pour montrer vraiment ce que c'est que
le karaté à savoir que
en 2020 ce quartier pas faire partie des
jo et donc c'est une bonne chose et
montrez vraiment ce que c'est que le
karaté ses valeurs la compétition ce que
c'est différent parce qu'on fait des
katas et les combats ce week end vous
salissez spectaculaire le karaté bien
sûr c'est toujours spectaculaire
c'est un sport pour avoir bien sûr réel
je veux montrer aux autres ce que le
karaté représente au sein du sport vous
avez participez vous à moi j'apprécie je
enseignants catégorie à moins de 84 kg
est ce que c'est une compétition que
vous aviez noter dans votre calendrier
depuis de la blessure depuis le début de
saison parce que ces qualificatifs pour
les ile-de-france et suite à cela si on
gagne enfin on fait partie des deux
premiers aux yvelines on accède
directement au championnat de france
championnat régional au niveau du cou de
la compétition est ce qu'au niveau sera
relevé bien sûr il ya des très bons
compétiteurs ont un accent pas mal
d'expérience et moussan fait partie de
cette élite
il est très complet et à dispose de pas
mal de qualités qu'il a acquis à travers
des entraînements qui dégrade par
s'écoute pas par son coach et donc on
compte sur lui pour ramener des
résultats et ainsi que d'autres membres
du club président tous les meilleurs
judokas vrai karatékas pardon des
ailiers l'abscisse karatékas adhésives
line viendront pour la compétition ah
oui tout à fait c'est justement un point
de rencontre important
ils viendront de partout des yvelines
enfin de toutes les yvelines
il va y avoir une trentaine de clubs qui
vont venir ah non leurs meilleurs
compétiteurs
et je pense que chez nous on va faire
deux bons très bons résultats
comment on prépare au mieux cette
compétition à se prépare c'est un
travail en amont travail sur la
préparation physique préparation mentale
parce que sans les sens les deux même si
on est très bon techniquement on peut
pas pour accéder à un titre mais donc
comme jeudi la préparation physique et
ensuite au fur et à mesure on travaille
la technique jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
dernière semaine où le dernier mois on
et focus plutôt sur la technique de
façon que le jour j ai aucun problème la
machine à dérégler on a juste à déroule
vous avez un objectif de résultat
championnat de france champion de france
pour notre poule 1 où s'allient donc
moussavi qui est la meilleure chance du
club lui d'autres médias plus
d'expérience puisqu'il a fait plusieurs
plusieurs titres en championnat de
france plusieurs podiums en ile de
france
il a pas mal d'expérience et il
s'entraîne aussi avec l'équipe de france
au creps serait donc c'est une pépite
quand qu'on a et on tient absolument à
ce qu' il montre le club de plaisir ce
qui vaut et je pense qu'au delà des
bonnes chances est ce que le président a
fixé un objectif aux athlètes du club
oui évidemment donc c'est de leur
ramener un maximum british et dès que
possible que ceci n'est pas d'objectif
chiffré
c'est à dire vous n'avez pas un nombre
précis de
deux places de première place visé
abassi s'ils peuvent tous y aller c'est
à dire que là on propose presque 13 13
compétiteurs si les treize arrive dans
les premières places
pour moi ça sera très bien savoir qu'un
dernier on avait fait une razzia avec
pas mal de titres ça a été un come back
pour certains d'entre nous et donc on
veut réitérer ce ce qui s'est passé l'an
dernier plaisir est l'un des plus gros
club des yvelines
est ce que c'est le meilleur club des
yvelines pour moi oui c'est leur club on
a des bons profs un bon prof même est un
un bon bureau aussi il faut pas
l'oublier et donc sans sa loncin travail
d'équipé comme on dit malgré ce malgré
qu'on soit tous soient sont à tamié ont
fait partie d'une équipe et on va dire
chacun ramène sa sa petite touche pour
pouvoir accéder quoi vous saviez vous
confirmez génération d'un désir ah oui
je fais une petite dédicace à un mauvais
coach mohamed guendouzi espère qu'il
verra ce reportage scénario n'en doute
pas syndiqués alors il y aura également
la présence du double champion du monde
antonio dias il proposera des stages le
samedi sa venue ça va booster encore
plus la fréquentation de l'événement
ah oui totalement le fait d'avoir un
champion du monde un double champion du
monde de kata individuel qui vient du
venezuela après la préparation pour
l'open de paris
c'est quelque chose de très important et
nous faire un stage et avoir la chance
d'avoir un stage avec ce genre de
personnage c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
qu'est ce que ça va apporter justement
sa venue étant donné que c'est un titre
riche au niveau mondial
il va nous montrer vraiment quel raté
sous toute sa splendeur on va dire c'est
toute la technique comme on est comment
gérer comment faire son kata
correctement aura peut-être apporter
quelque chose de nouveau comme peut-être
qu'on connaît pas on à façon on est là
pour apprendre tous les jours donc on
apprend tous les jours et c'est un prof
qui vient sera champion du monde redire
preuve qui va nous montrer une autre
espèce d'autre part cette perspective
par nom des autres techniques et
pourquoi pas en apprendre davantage
le sellier en tant qu'athlète ça vous
fait quoi de voir un champion comme
anthony niasse a déjà ça nous fait rêver
parce qu'on n'a pas la chance de voir
tous les jours un double champion du
monde sur toi plaisir tu qu'on va
prendre exemple sur lui et si d'arriver
comme lui pour être peut-être un jour
champion jim ça va vous motiver encore
plus sommes pour la compétition doit
beaucoup plus comme vous allez lui
demander des conseils
merci sur ces permissions à l'espagnol à
la commission vous êtes prêt tout
simplement président pour pour cette
grand événement oui tout à fait oui on a
encore fait les derniers whiting
derniers jours mais on est vraiment prêt
que ce soit les coaches ce soit les
compétiteurs ou que ce soit le bureau
chez nous régit tous les bénévoles qui
vont être présents pour cette cette
compétition merci à tous les trois le
passé sur ce plateau on vous souhaite
bon courage pour l'organisation de cet
événement et beaucoup de médailles pour
le gloss et on continuera à vous sur sur
tv soixante dix huit du tennis à présent
la 15e édition de l'open de tennis de la
verrière a débuté ce week-end au parc
sportif philippe cousteau
plus de 150 participants se sont
inscrits pour la compétition dont 60%
divine oit les finales se dérouleront le
dimanche 4 février si vous voulez
assister au match l'entrée est libre
le juge habits arbitre du tournoi nous
donne le programme de la compétition le
week-end si on va dire que c'est une
quinzaine de matches plein jour samedi
et ceci donc sur trois semaines et on
semaine donc lundi au vendredi on a six
matchs par par jour un petit peu limité
au niveau des créneaux monadé match qui
démarre à 18 heures pour se finir à ça
peut aller jusqu'à jusqu'à minuit au
pire on va dire et on termine par du
football et le championnat de première
division de district le ch est né
recevra montigny le bretonneux ce
dimanche 21 janvier à 15 heures au stade
michaud pour le compte de la 12e journée
du championnat à match crucial pour les
inimités 1 qui sont actuellement
derniers du championnat avec une seule
victoire au compteur depuis septembre le
chesnais est lui classé à la 8e place
c'est la fin de ce statut de sport merci
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]